- [Voiceover] What is the
area of the shaded figure?
So down here we have
this green shaded figure,
and it looks like a rectangle
except it has a square
cut out in the middle.
So when we find its
area, we can think of it
exactly like that.
We want to know how much space it covers.
It covers this rectangle's amount of area
with this square cut out.
So what we can do is find the
area of the larger rectangle
and then cut out or subtract
the area of the square
to see what's left in this shaded area.
So let's start by finding the area
of this larger rectangle.
And to do that, we can
look at the side lengths.
It has side lengths of nine and eight.
To find the area of a
rectangle, we can multiple
the side lengths.
So nine times eight is 72.
So that means that this rectangle
covers 72 square centimeters.
This entire rectangular area
But now we need to cut out or subtract
the area of this square
'cause that's not part
of our shaded figure.
We need to cut that part out.
So to do that, we know
the side lengths are four
on the square so we can think of this as
this is four centimeters
across so we can divide it
into four equal sections,
and same going this way,
and then if we connect these lines,
what it will show us is that we have,
it's not drawn perfect,
but we have four rows
of four square centimeters.
Four times we see four square centimeters.
This top row, one, two,
three, four, and so on.
Four rows, so there's
16 square centimeters
we need to cut out of the 72
of this entire rectangular area,
we need to cut out or subtract
16 of these square centimeters.
So let's do that.
We have 72 as the entire area,
and then let's start subtracting out.
We subtract out 10 of them,
just for me like subtracting
10s 'cause they're simpler.
So four, eight, 10 of
the square centimeters.
Now we're down an area of 62 left.
And then let's subtract those two more.
We'll get us to subtract
two more, will get us to 60.
And then there's four
left to subtract in order
to subtract all 16, so 60 minus four
gets us to 56.
So the entire area of 72,
we subtracted out these
16 square centimeters,
leaves us with a final area of 56
square centimeters.